[Music]
first at 11 a protest erupts outside of
ccsd board president linda cavazo's home
tonight this after the board fired
superintendent dr jesus jar three weeks
ago then voted to reinstate him last
week thank you for joining us at 11 i'm
brian loftis i'm denise valdez so now
this fight is getting personal as you
saw in that video 30 to 40 people
protested outside her home cavazos is
known for leading the board through that
vote to fire the superintendent then a
week later a vote to give him his job
back madison kimbrough on this story
live in henderson with what happened
there tonight
yeah it's quiet here now but tense
moments for cavazos and her neighbors as
i spoke to her earlier about the protest
at her house she says they are still in
shock
this video taken by cavazo's husband
shows the number of protesters who
rattled this henderson neighborhood
sunday afternoon i spoke with the board
president by phone who suddenly heard
yelling outside
they were yelling about
mask mandates and about
the covid virus being fake
and that we were
suffocating their children with math
ccsd police had been on standby all
weekend warned about a possible protest
cavazos admits she feared for her
family's safety and her neighbors too
we have been able to see that at least
two or three looks like two definitely
came up to the front door
i was
on the other side of the door so i could
hear very clearly
the comments that were being made the
group leveled insults and she claims
they even threatened to burn her house
down she also heard protesters say katie
sent us possibly referencing katie
williams another ccsd board member in a
statement trustee williams posted on
twitter stating i not now nor have i
ever supported protesting outside of a
personal residence of any public figure
nor have i ever directed individuals to
do so after a few hours the group left
and no one was hurt